- My name's Shibani Ahuja.
I'm gonna say a couple word,
I'll share a few slides now
that they're working, excellent.
And then I'd love to introduce
a friend of mine, Sameer,
but I'd like to make fun
of him before we start.
The last time he and I
were on stage together
I was in four-inch stilettos
and like an evening gown,
and he was dressed like a scrub.
So he's giving me a hard time
that I dressed for my audience.
I came prepared, I've worn
my Big Data Energy hat.
Next time, Sameer, know
your audience, okay?
(Sameer laughing)
- So, I'm Shibani Ahuja.
I have been at Salesforce for one year.
November 18th marked my
one-year anniversary.
Before being at Salesforce,
I was sitting in your seat.
So I worked at TD Bank,
it's one of the largest banks in Canada.
I headed up their digital
banking for a little while,
and I ran a number of their
technologies across the globe.
And how I ended up in the role that I'm in
is Salesforce loves to tell
customer success stories.
So they invited me to
an internal conference
of just their employees
in a room for about 450 people.
Mark Benioff was sitting where you are,
and they're asking me about
the personalization at scale
and all these things that we did.
At the end, he asked me one
question, "What advice,"
you know, Mark Benioff
is sitting right here,
"What advice do you have for the company?"
And I let it rip.
Like I made it stand up comedy.
I was on a roll
that I couldn't even stop
making fun of the company.
And I would say things like, you know,
"It's ironic that you're helping me
"put my customer at the center,
"yet when I show up
for a meeting with you,
"22 of you show up."
And I just went on, and on and on.
Next thing you know, I'm sure
I'm gonna get kicked out,
and the next thing you
know, as I'm walking out,
someone says, "Watch out,
they're coming for you."
And so now, I am on the Salesforce side,
and I have one of the coolest
jobs where I ultimately,
I'm helping the company build
out, our go to market strategy
for how we engage CIOs, in
the office of the CIO and CEOs
and CFOs and COOs.
So all the C-Suite,
what that translates into is I actually
get to just travel the world,
and I meet with enterprise
CIOs of all industries,
all shapes and sizes.
I just got my latest count,
I've hit now four, 520 CIOs
in the course of a year.
And these are meaningful engagements.
Why I share this
is because it comes into a
couple of the trends and patterns
that I've observed as it
relates to this little thing
called AI over the course of the year.
Before I get into sharing any of those,
I have been obligated by my legal team
to share a love letter with you.
So this is the love
letter for my legal team
to say, "Please make
any purchasing decisions
"that you are going to make
"on generally available products today,
"not of anything that you might
see that's future looking."
So, 520 CIOs, I've gone through
and seen a lot of trends.
One of which is the fact
that AI has become the
smallest, biggest word.
It's become the fastest growing thing
that everyone needs to implement,
they have to rush to get
something into production.
And CIOs are in a hot seat right now
where unlike cloud, or mobile or internet,
where they were squarely
in the driver's seat
and they were doing it,
like implementing it on
behalf of their organizations,
Suddenly everyone with Chat
GPT has become an expert at AI.
Boards are putting pressure,
CEOs are putting pressure,
everyone is putting all
this pressure on CIOs
to get something implemented.
And what's happened is,
in the early stages of the
year, CIOs were, you know,
Salesforce as an
organization would come in
and you would see these CIOs would say,
"No, no, no, I'm a build
shop, I'm gonna build my own."
And why I say AI is the
smallest, biggest word
is because I was starting
to learn the differences
between predictive, versus generative,
versus agentic architecture.
But these CIOs would just say,
"No, no, I'm gonna build my own."
And it would surprise me to say, like,
"You really wanna build
the component parts
"for agentic architecture?
"And do you actually
fundamentally understand
"what agentic AI is?
"What the difference between a copilot
"or generative and agentic?"
And so it was adamantly this conversation,
I'm gonna, it's build versus buy.
I'm gonna DIY.
I think as CIOs started to,
and tech leaders started to understand,
no, there is actually a
fundamental difference
between generative, and
generative and agentic,
then the conversation shifted again.
And the conversation started
to shift a bit more to,
Well, maybe not build versus buy,
but I'm gonna start to
look at maybe platforms
like a SaaS platform that's gonna allow me
to move with speed.
And they're gonna, they're
gonna have templates
and I can do it really quickly.
And you know, a lot of
my like customer data
is already within Salesforce,
so let me leverage that
because it seems to be a
good smart place to be.
There would be others that
would have a different approach
and they might say,
"Well, no, I'm like, I'm
not gonna look at Salesforce
"for AI, they're my CRM company."
There's others that would say,
"I'm gonna go to the Amazons of the world.
"I'm gonna go to AWS, I want
to cloud service provider.
"They're gonna give me
infinite scale and uptime,
"and I'm gonna have governance,
and protection and security.
"I'm gonna be able to build
my own customized agents."
And it was, again, I saw
the debate shifting from DIY
to not to build versus buy
to now this one to say,
"No, I'm gonna do a SaaS
provider and I'm gonna do."
There's a world where both exists.
And that's what we're
gonna share about today.
Is I think now the latest iteration,
and it's about a month-and-a-half
that I've started to hear
more and more of this.
less to build or buy.
Less, it's gonna be a SaaS platform
or I'm gonna use a cloud service provider.
Now it has shifted
to Agentic, native Agentic integration.
At TD
My MarTech stack alone
was 90 technologies.
I couldn't imagine ripping all of that out
and starting fresh because they,
I've got a 4-year-old at home,
so I describe a agentic architecture
as like the steel or the
metal in Wolverine's body.
I'm not, no one's gonna
architect that from scratch,
that's pretty tough to do.
And so now, I'm hearing a lot of CIOs say,
"I need to look at the partners
"that I've already invested in,
"the technologies that I
already have in my shop,
"And I'd like to start
looking at who is doing
"the work for me to build these
agentic native integrations
"such that we can move with speed."
And that is the better together story.
'Cause I think that there has been,
wait, Salesforce, don't
you compete with AWS
in certain spaces?
But that's not the case.
So I am so thrilled to
introduce Sameer from Capita,
who again, a friend of mine.
Come on up.
- Hello.
- Nice to see you again.
- We are friends, see?
- We are, we are.
we are legitimately friends.
So I can tease him.
And Capita has become
an agentic enterprise
where leveraging Salesforce
and Amazon Bedrock,
he is an example of how
we have come together
to really be able to
drive agents at scale.
And Sameer, when we
were prepping for this,
one of the things that
you had talked about
was that you've got four use cases
specifically that you're looking at
that are linked to both
Amazon Bedrock and Agentforce.
Tell us a bit about those four use cases.
- Yeah, first of all,
absolutely thrilled to
be back at Reinvent.
I was at AWS until exactly
this day a year ago.
- Oh.
- So it's great to come
back as a customer.
You actually walk less, believe
it or not, as a customer.
So absolutely thrilled.
And I've seen what Salesforce
has done with AWS in the past
from the inside, and now I see
it from the outside as well.
And so when I took on this new role
to introduce agentic
workflows into Capita,
there was a lot of noise
about which platform to use.
Who do we engage with?
Do we go with an SI?
And there were these,
and the fundamental thing
that Jeff Bezos actually said was,
"In times of uncertainty,
"build on something that doesn't change."
And I know what won't
change, AWS will be here.
Salesforce will be here.
- Yeah.
- And so when I looked at
what we needed to build
across the multiple use cases we have,
and we run everything
from transport for London
to training nuclear submarine operators.
My biggest need was to
democratize the ability
to build agents across
all of my organization.
And so we looked at four different
use cases to get started.
The first one is we had,
as Shibani mentioned,
she said, 90, I have a customer
who's about 65 right now,
different applications.
And you create the rip and replace
or you could go over the top with MuleSoft
and create that cover
and then start building agents
on top very, very easily.
And that's one that we use all the time.
And then for our contact center space,
the integration with Amazon Connect
and that exposure into Agentforce,
we're actually building agents,
voice agents in Agentforce today
and deploying them at scale
using both Amazon Connect,
Invoicecloud and Salesforce.
We are using Missionforce
for our defense applications.
We are building local government in a box.
And all of these that used to take years
and frankly tens of
millions of pounds to build,
we're now building in months
and deploying at scale.
- And, you know, for the audience
that may or may not be
familiar with Capita,
maybe give even like a brief overview of-
- Absolutely.
- Like what Capita is, what's
the business that you're in?
- So Capita is the largest
UK based public sector BPO,
business process outsourcer.
So if you really look at the
kind of services we operate,
we touch 70% of the UK's
population every single week.
From running civil service pensions,
which we went live with two days ago,
to transport for London,
which I mentioned,
to doing recruitment for the British Army.
And everywhere it is
such a diverse use case
that is very, very process heavy.
And that's ripe for electrification.
And that's why we're there
because human labor is gonna go infinite.
It is gonna be scalable, it
is gonna be available 24/7,
and that's the mission that we're after.
- So Sameer, here's another
connect that we have.
Like BPO, I used to
live in the Philippines
and I was setting up a captive BPO.
It is a human intensive
function or department.
Like how are you looking at,
we've talked a lot about
agents, human agents,
and digital labor coming together.
Like how are you looking at that strategy
being a very, like,
human-heavy organization?
What's the strategy of bringing AI
and your colleagues together?
- It, in the immortal
words of a guy called Phil,
just do it.
So there's a lot of fud in the market
about agentification that
it's going to take jobs,
reduce labor.
We saw exactly the opposite
when we introduced agents
to our customer advisors
who actually run that contact center.
If you ever been on a contact center
and you've been passed around
department to department,
we all have right?
For hours and hours,
you're super frustrated.
But guess who's more frustrated than you?
It's actually the customer
advisor on the other end.
'Cause he or she did not have the tools
to actually resolve your problem.
Once we gave our advisors those tools,
they actually started pulling on us
and giving us more use
cases for agentification.
And that started this virtual cycle where,
when we started with 10 advisors,
all thousand plus advisors
actually literally came to us
and said, "I want some of that."
Because they do not want to
be writing up transcripts.
They do not want to be marking themselves.
They don't want the supervisor
looking over their shoulder.
It's just a better life,
they're more satisfied,
they're happier.
And that's translating into
customer NPS improvements
for our contact centers.
- Yeah.
On that and the use cases
that you've talked about,
how are you measuring?
So measurement, true
measurement was a hot topic.
Last night I hosted a dinner with CIOs
and one of the hottest
topics that came up was, yep,
we're attributing a lot of benefits to AI.
But tracing it back was very difficult
because many organizations
didn't have that baseline.
How are you looking at
the measurement of AI
and are you telling the story?
- Yeah, so three different vectors really.
One, we run a lot of
contracts that have KPIs.
And when we don't execute to
those KPIs, we incur penalties.
But when we exceed those KPIs,
we share in the profits with the customer.
So actually looking at that KPI
and saying A, can we eliminate
all of these penalties?
We've eliminated double
digit million pounds
of penalties in a contract.
- Wow.
- Just by identifying the bottleneck.
And that drops straight
to the bottom line.
It's not new revenue, but it's even better
'cause it's a hundred
percent margin, right?
And we share that with the customer.
- Yeah.
- And then number two, we are embedding AI
into every single bid
that we put out there.
Every single one.
And we are seeing a win rate increase
because we are cheaper, we are faster,
and we are more flexible
in what we are providing to the customer.
So that's number two.
And then number three, just for us
to become an agentic enterprise,
we have democratized access to
low-code development of agents
across all of our customers,
all of our employees.
And we're actually measuring what they,
what agents they've built
and what actions they're taking.
And at this point, we are attributing
a fiat currency to each one of them.
But the customer and
the employee NPS, sorry,
is actually a good representation
of how well they're actually adopting it
and how happy they are with
it, and it is going up.
- What I, so again, if I
think about the trends,
an evolution that I've
seen as it relates to AI,
I love what you've just called out
is that not one of your measurements
was how many FTEs are you reducing?
- None at all.
- Right? Like, this is
again, a healthy way
of starting to think about those use cases
and looking at the growth opportunities
or the expansion opportunities.
And I had actually, it was, it
was also for Capita, I think
that I was presenting and
speaking on your behalf,
saying that there was a
contact center opportunity
that you had a use case where
your contact center was open nine to five.
- Correct.
- And suddenly when you
implemented Agentforce
to help support the contact center agents
such that the agent could handle
the more, like, mundane tasks,
suddenly your contact center
became from nine to five,
became overnight, it was 24/7.
Because there was transactions
that could be performed,
or there was cases that could
be resolved by the agent.
And that's again, another
way of looking at it,
to say that's a reverse
benefit to your colleagues,
the change management around adoption.
- Yeah, that's a great use case.
And I'm going to go even further.
- Yeah.
- Historically we used to
have a customer advisor
dedicated to an account, because he or she
needed to know everything
about that account
and how to operate within the
constraints of that account.
We are now able to time
division multiplex.
These highly capable agents
across multiple different accounts
just by providing on-demand knowledge base
and real time assistance
using, in this case,
generative AI and transcription,
not necessarily an agent.
- Right, right.
- And the next step is going to be enable,
give them agents to enable them to do
first call resolution.
Much, much better.
- Wow, love it.
Okay, so you have a unique position here
in that you clearly, you know Salesforce,
you've got Salesforce in your ecosystem,
you're familiar with
it, we get you on stage,
you help tell the story.
But being only a year away from AWS
and working at Capita,
you know, in your words,
what are the benefits of
this better together story?
Like, do it better than me on stage.
(Sameer laughing)
- Tell the audience.
- Look, I'm a geek, right?
And this is the only suit I wear.
- I do have the hat, I don't think so.
- Yeah, okay, I would always love to go in
and do assembly level code.
- Yeah.
- If given a choice.
- Yep.
- But I don't want, I can't, right.
So, one of the things that
Salesforce has brought
is the elevation of
enabling everyone in my org
to basically go in and
describe with natural language
what they want to do for their customer,
and to test it out with their customer
without my involvement.
- Right.
- Or any of my team's involvement,
team sitting over there,
but they're enabling teams now.
They don't necessarily have to build
for the customer anymore.
All they do is advise and guide.
Yeah? They are the Yodas.
- Yeah.
- Right?
(both laughing)
- Love it.
- Right? So we have a bunch of Yodas,
but we have a lot of Jedi Knights now
is the way I'd look at it.
- Amazing.
- And every single one of my
employees, Capita's employees
is a padawan, hopefully
will become a Jedi knight.
- We're geeking out now.
- In the future.
I am, absolutely.
Hey, it comes out
- And, but I think like from
a partnership perspective,
the fact that you can
now purchase Salesforce
on the AWS Marketplace or-
- Absolutely.
- The model optionality.
I think, again, as a
customer, I thought Salesforce
was one of these big bad
wolves that say, like,
"You've gotta have
everything in Salesforce,
"you've gotta buy every module
"in order to get all the benefits."
But then to learn that it's
a interoperable open stack
that's allowing you to choose your models.
And in this case, you know, Bedrock,
being able to choose through Bedrock.
- Look, financially for
us, it made a lot of sense.
- Yeah.
- Because it runs on AWS,
allows us to retire AWS Commit.
It's like, it's a no brainer,
why wouldn't you do that?
- Yeah.
- Number one.
Number two, you are the absolute experts
in the Salesforce ecosystem
and you have tens of
thousands of use cases
that you're already identifying.
- Right.
- Why would we recreate that?
- Why won't we use what
you've already built?
And it's available on
Agentforce Marketplace
and on the AWS Marketplace
and have it securely governed.
With what I know is the best
security platform on Earth.
- Fabulous.
- Is AWS.
- I'm gonna have to slip this
guy some money afterwards.
Okay, last question as we wrap it up.
You've got the audience here,
you've got a lot of folks here.
Three, like, three key takeaways
that you give to the audience
as it relates to agentic AI.
- First of all, build on something
that you know is gonna be
there for the long term.
You are going to get inundated
by everyone who's specializing
in a single use case.
But the beauty of agentic
AI is that you can adapt
to any use case as long as
you have the right platform
and the global reach.
And that's what the AWS and
Agentforce capability gives you.
- Right.
- You can build your own, start building.
No one knows the process
that you're doing,
the job that you're doing better than you.
Build for yourself,
then share it with your employees.
- Great.
- And look, that's it.
And you will see the value.
And then, you know, last one, have fun.
I literally have fun every day.
I'm like, I had an SI come
in the other day saying,
I'm gonna charge you 2
million pounds to do this.
I went and wipe cutted it on Salesforce.
- Yep.
- And, I showed it to the SI
in like half an hour, right?
This world is changing, start building.
- Perfect.
- If I can build, so can you.
- So have fun, here's
a few ways to have fun.
Come visit us, you can
build agents at our booth.
Come check this out, learn
more about the partnership
between Salesforce and AWS.
If this is part of your
stack, learn much more.
Contact your account
reps if you have a rep.
If not, come talk to us
if you're interested,
you know, don't know what Salesforce is,
happy to talk about that.
And it's a pleasure, thank you.
Thank you, Sameer.
Love it.
I will hopefully see
you again on the stage.
- See you soon.
- But thank you all for coming.
(audience applauding)
- [Sameer] Kiss me, thank you so much.